Hello
bitches,
you,
um,
we were talking about what I think we
say Kratom I think we can call Kratom and
um,
this is something that is in the news
right now because it's helped a lot of
people overcome opioid addiction and
they're about to make it schedule one
meaning that it has no
medical use whatsoever.
No highly addictive.
You know,
medical use.
We are going to take it right now,
like on this podcast right now.
It's legal to do and boy,
they're going to get you
record right retroactive.
Come on.
I know the statue of limitations
on the illegal drugs.
It takes like an hour to kick in.
And so,
and this is a very mild dose.
It is 1223,
one 23.
Emma started asking you weird questions.
I'm already on some,
oh,
you already handsome before you
just taking this shit all day long.
Uh,
no.
Um,
let's take it in the more I do podcasts.
Well,
um,
I still have some pain management issues
from an injury and the injury cause
it's crazy.
It's crazy story.
Uh,
so I was,
this is a couple of years ago.
I,
I was in the best shape of my life
and I was rock climbing like three,
four times a week and doing
crossfit and all this.
And I was like,
I,
I've always been lanky
like this my whole life.
And I actually had muscles for the first
time in my life and just like felt like
superman.
And,
and I was supposed to be rock
climbing is on my birthday.
And,
um,
and there's some fires in Sedona where
the rock climbing was supposed to be.
And so,
so we went for a hike instead just to
see a little bit of Sedona as my first
time there.
And I was out with my friend,
um,
Mikey and he,
so he,
he was like this,
he was like three,
400 pounds,
I think he was like 400 pounds.
Um,
like his whole life,
he's been a hugely obese.
And then he went on this diet that he
just drank coffee with butter in it for
like 40 days.
That's it.
That's all he ate.
He cracked himself out.
And then he,
uh,
how much did he lose in 40 days?
So like a thousand pounds,
200 pounds.
He lost all of his weight.
And then he was like a normal person.
That sounds crazy.
I know it's 200 pounds in 40 days.
I don't know if it was that much.
It was significant.
It was like well over a hundred pounds.
And He,
um,
and then he,
so then he started doing like Jujitsu.
It started like becoming active for like
the first time in his life and was like
all excited about this.
And so he was like,
oh,
I have this,
there's this one shortcut
that I want to take.
My,
my wife will never let me and so let's,
let's go and do that now.
And I liked that it let me take a shortcut
because it was too high of a jump.
And then I,
and we got to this and um,
and I looked and I was like,
yeah,
that's too high.
And he was like,
so because he's been
so huge his whole life,
he has no idea of how high
you can jump from like this,
you know,
he's,
he's never been able to play before.
And I know,
cause I'm an adrenaline junkie.
I love heights.
I've been climbing trees and
jumping off shit my whole life.
And um,
and I was like,
this is too high.
And he's like,
I think if we like climb down a little,
it would be okay on like,
I don't know,
I was wearing barefoot running shoes at
the time and then he was like determined
he was going to do it and high psych.
So it was jumping from a
cliff onto another cliff.
And so if you couldn't roll and if you
landed it wrong and you rolled off,
it was like death,
death,
hundreds of feet.
And um,
and uh,
and so now I'm like,
I'm going to watch this guy roll off
this cliff because he's new to like
physical activity.
It doesn't know what the fuck he's doing.
And he's about to jump off this thing
that's to lie on the other side.
He's been carrying around an extra
hundred plus pounds on his legs his whole
life.
His legs would probably strong as hell.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I imagine.
And it was weird because
he had like weird skin,
like hanging off everywhere.
It's tough from all from and
like stretch marks and stuff.
But he,
um,
so he was,
he was determined and I was like,
I was looking at it and I was like,
you know what?
I think that I could make it.
Oh,
and then I can,
I can like at least be there.
So he makes sure he doesn't roll
off this fucking cliff front of me.
God.
And um,
yeah.
I mean,
you know,
it's one of those things,
you feel like a fool in hindsight.
And I,
I was like,
you know,
I've,
I've jumped off stuff higher than this.
It's just that I'm wearing
bad shoes and I can't roll.
I'm going to have to take it with my feet.
And I even told them,
I was like,
I'm going to be risking breaking a heel
because I broke a heel once before when
I was like a teenager.
I love jumping off shit.
Um,
and so,
but it wasn't like the end of the world.
I was like,
you know,
if that,
if I break a heel it won't,
I'll still be able to get around.
It's just like a couple month thing.
And I,
in my mind this is the worst
of what's going to happen.
And so I went for it and I,
and I jumped and I landed and um,
and then,
and I,
as soon as I landed,
I heard both of my heels break.
Um,
it just,
the sound shot through my
body and I heard it like,
it sounded like a branch,
like snapping underwater.
And,
and I,
I was,
I think I was in shock or something
cause I just kind of turned and looked at
him.
I was like,
I just broke both my heels
and I said it just like that.
And so he thought I was like joking.
So he was just about to do,
I'm like,
no,
no.
I really broke both my heels.
You're going to have to go
around and try to help me down.
And I started making my way down.
It took them like a half hour,
45 minutes to get to me.
And I had to kind of,
uh,
do you remember when you were
in school in gym class to be,
you have to do that crab walk thing
where like your bellies facing the air?
Um,
so I had my left foot just was,
was already like five times that
size within like 30 seconds.
And so I couldn't use that at all.
And then my,
my right foot,
it's just a,
I couldn't even tell if it was totally
broken and for if I just bruised it real
bad,
but I was able to use my toes thankfully.
And so I had to kind of
like a w one foot crab walk,
uh,
down.
And then he got around to me and was like,
a couple of people were trying
to help me for a little bit,
but it's too steep for anyone to help me.
So I just kinda had to make it down on
my own once we were at level ground,
which took like three hours,
um,
of just like,
it,
it was an exceptionally annoying,
uh,
Eh,
I mean it was painful.
I,
I'd scoot down for a little bit and
then I'd have to take a break for a few
minutes and just like,
and then just like roll around in
the fetal position and pain and,
um,
and then,
and he was like,
he was like,
so this was his dumb idea.
And on the way down he's just like
standing there like next to me waiting for
me,
like trying to lighten the mood
by telling me jokes and stuff.
I'm like,
dude,
this is not the time for jokes.
I am fucking pissed right now.
And um,
I was like,
it's okay.
It's fine.
It's going to be fine.
I just fucking need to focus and
get through this and got down,
went to the hospital.
I still,
I mean it hurt real bad and we had to
go to a second hospital because the one
was too full.
And,
and then,
I mean,
I thought it was bad,
but I thought I was like,
this is more than just a little break.
This is like,
this is a pretty big break.
And another doctor came in and he's like,
this is,
this is really serious and uh,
and your,
your heels and like 20 pieces.
Jesus give him extra so I could freak out.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's actually the,
the,
I I made an album about
it called my belt break.
And that's ball,
that's the cover art as this the x ray of,
of my heel.
So what's these big just re post surgery?
It's got all the screws and plates in it.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know.
I imagine I have the
originals around somewhere.
Um,
and I'm maybe somewhere
way back in my Facebook,
you could see some of the
scars and stuff like that.
It's real grill,
so I'm not sure if you'd
be able to find it or not.
Um,
but,
uh,
so,
so they put these metal plates in it and
kind of screwed in the pieces of the,
the bigger pieces of the
bone that were still there,
like where they wanted
them to be eventually.
Cause it's,
you can't just put the bone,
it's like if you,
if you snap like a candy bar
and try to put it together,
there's all these crumbs
and stuff like that missing.
And so they just kind of put it in
place where it was supposed to be and,
and,
um,
and they were like,
well,
hopefully it just kinda grows
back and comes together.
Right.
And,
um,
and it did really,
the issue was so they,
um,
the way they did the surgery,
they told me I had a time,
ladies and gentlemen,
it's a first,
you see that?
What am I looking at right here?
Yeah.
What is that?
That's the,
from where they went in with the surgery.
Okay.
So,
um,
they,
they said that they didn't want to do
the surgery at first cause they're like
this is really complicated surgery,
but if we don't do it,
I don't think you're ever
going to walk right again.
And why did they not want to do it?
They weren't qualified to do it.
Is that the idea?
No,
this guy was like,
Eh,
this guy I got referrals and this
guy was like as good of theirs.
Theirs go further back than that.
There's some real disgusting stuff.
Um,
so um,
they just,
just the area that it's in and,
and so there's,
this is,
it's like a 90 degree angle
that they have to cut in,
in the corner of it.
Oh there we go.
That doesn't look good.
That,
and that was like,
that was like months and months later
too that this is a post surgery.
This is like four months after the fact
that it looks like what it looked like.
Tissue.
Yeah,
a lot of scar tissue and stuff.
So see where it's open there and
in that that corner ripped open.
They're like,
I hope this corner doesn't rip open cause
as sometimes happens with this surgery
and if it does,
you're going to be really
susceptible to infection.
And so I had,
I couldn't,
when I,
I at the time I lived in Malibu and my
place had like 50 steps and there's no
way I could like get up with groceries
and everything with two broken feet.
I could get around on
crutches a little bit.
But,
uh,
I ended up having to spend like three
months in my parents' basement cause I
couldn't care for myself or anything.
So like on top of having to cancel
three months of work and not have,
you know,
we don't have a safety net and
having no income and you know,
it's,
it,
it was,
it was actually like,
I'm very grateful for my parents and,
but it's,
you know,
it's just embarrassing and you're like,
I had to move him in my parents' basement.
I'm sure they understand though.
I mean,
it's not like you just,
you know,
we were a loser and
couldn't wake up on time,
lost your apartment.
You know,
this is just fuck man.
Got worst part of it,
come to start walking again.
So after three months I got
back on the road and um,
and there was still this,
this little kind of
wound that it opened up,
wasn't healing.
And then I started,
it was just taking the,
they told me it was going to take like
at least six months to like start walking
and it ended up taking much longer
than that because so about four or five
months in,
I got on the road and then um,
and then a,
a doctor thought that maybe I was getting
a like just a topical infection and
gave me some stuff that wasn't
good enough for the infection.
And then I started,
so about four or five months later I
started having fevers and then I went into
the hospital and then they're like,
you have a bone infection.
And I was like,
Oh God.
Cause they are like this is really serious
because that's when you can lose your
foot and stuff.
If they can't stop the infection,
they just have to cut it off.
Oh Jesus came back,
canceled every,
all my work again.
Came back to La,
they did a surgery and um,
and I was really thankful that I had
happened to sign up for the health care.
This was right when the universal
health care just came out.
Otherwise I'd be bankrupt from it,
but it was still,
certainly,
it was not perfect at all.
Uh,
they wouldn't let me
do stuff out of state.
I had to get myself
back to California and,
and uh,
what do you mean by stuff out of state?
You mean surgical procedure?
Surgery and hospital checkups.
I had to pay,
they had to do with me in California
because of your insurance?
Yeah.
And so when I was in Wisconsin,
I had to pay out of pocket for that and,
and it's like kind of not
supposed to be that way either.
But there was the,
I mean,
I would,
I would call and try to,
in the insurance company would be like,
you need this one form.
Okay,
I call this company.
And they'd be like,
yeah,
only doctors can get that form.
And so I'd tell my
doctor and he'd be like,
no,
you can get that.
You have to go here.
And then it was like around and around.
Sometimes I'd have to like pretend I was
a doctor when I was on the phone with
people just to get this
fucking form that I need.
And so I paid out of pocket size,
like,
you know,
getting medical bills were piling up.
And so the second surgery,
what they did was they just cut out,
they took out the hardware,
that's what,
that's what got infected.
And then they kind of,
um,
we're where the holes
were from the screws.
They,
they kind of drill those out a little
bit and then they just cut off it cut as
big of a hole as they possibly could
in my foot to suck out as much of the
infection as possible.
And so I thought I was going
to be in a hospital for,
and I still hadn't walked at this point.
And then I thought I
was going to be there,
like you'll be in a hospital for
like a week and a half or so,
two weeks.
And I was like,
okay,
fine.
I like,
I'm in,
I finally,
someone's going to be
like taking care of me.
We're just going to get this done.
Right.
I have my computer,
I was in good spirits and,
and getting a lot of work done and stuff.
And um,
and then like two days
later they were like,
your insurance is saying that they think
you're better and you need to go home
and now we need to show you
how to like care for yourself.
So I had to train me on how to,
I had to give Myself Ivy
antibiotics three times a day.
But yeah,
they had,
they,
they put,
they put lines in my arm and I had to
like make sure that their sanitary all the
time and I'd have to get him in,
in,
hold on a second.
That's a complex medical procedure.
Giving yourself an ivy dude,
I had to Google it.
I like fucking Google.
What's the name of your insurance company?
Um,
I don't know.
Do I have the,
that's insane.
Um,
the fact and try,
so that's the other thing is I have
like two different insurance companies.
So this is like health net and then
there's like this lake side and medical,
which one?
And I can never know which one is like
the I call one and they'd be like,
no,
that's your,
your other company.
I call the other one.
No that's this kind of,
it was just a year of dealing with this.
So because of the fact
that this was so expensive,
they just decided to say fuck this guy.
Let's make him do all the
medical stuff himself.
Yeah.
They were like,
have you ever heard of that before?
And they're like,
well he's a young guy.
He seems like he's in
good spirits and healthy.
Seems like a bright guy.
Like he could take care of himself.
I think it was the logic behind it.
And so let's,
let's get them Outta here.
Cause he's the clients.
What's that?
Could you fight it?
I tried.
I was like,
what?
You're I,
I can't do this on my own.
When they showed me what I had to do,
it was so once I get the IBS hooked up
and I'd have to figure out how to like
get bubbles out of the
lines and stuff like that.
Like I was googling,
how do you get bubbles out of the lines?
And that's literally what I say.
Then I had to,
the first time they showed
me what I had to do,
I couldn't believe it.
They're like,
no,
watch this because you're going
to have to do this yourself.
And then,
so this huge hole in my foot was packed
full of gauze and they started pulling
out this gauze.
I didn't know how big
the hole was at first,
but then it was like one
of those magic scarves,
like wound on calming.
Yeah.
And,
and then they're like,
so you're gonna need to take
this out and then look in here,
look in your hole.
You're going to need to clean it out
and like clean off your bone and stuff
every day.
See your bone.
Oh yeah.
I had to like scrub it off and then,
and then I had to pack it full of Shit
again and all of this with like wearing
gloves in a fee,
a a mask and everything like that.
And,
and then I,
and then I'd have to like
put a rubber thing on to,
to take a shower.
I had to do this three times a day and
then I couldn't sleep either because I
needed the IB antibiotics had to be every
eight hours and it took two hours to
do them.
And so I could never get
like a full eight hour rest.
So I was like mad it up.
It took two hours for the
IB fluids to go and okay.
Yeah.
So you have to do,
oh so I'd hang up these bags and stuff.
I'd hook up the IBS,
then I'd spend 20 minutes
with my foot hole and then,
and then after,
after like a few weeks of that,
see they would always be like okay
we can get you another home visit or
something like that.
It would be like a week
after I actually needed it.
Cause then I got,
I got this vacuum Suction Cup thing
that they put on my feet and um,
and they,
uh,
and it just kind of sucks all
the infection stuff out and,
and uh,
uh,
gets,
gets rid of it and closes up in,
creates like blood flow into that area.
So it generates the things
actually work amazingly.
But,
but so then I had this device and like
a vacuum and I started performing again.
I'd have to like take this vacuum off
myself and I close up my fucking foot hole
and then go on stage and perform and
then get off and put this back Hume back
on.
And,
and uh,
uh,
I remember,
cause I had before I,
before I,
um,
I went through a big breakup,
before I broke my feet and when I,
and I had been in like 12
years of relationships.
And so I was like,
I'm not dating for a year.
I'm not going to have sex.
I'm not going to think
about women for a year.
I'm just going to get my head straight.
And I did that.
It was great.
Got Tons of work done.
And then,
then when I started
getting back into things,
you broke a fee.
It was uh,
no,
I had already,
I broke my feet during this time,
which helped when like QC spell have
a sex drive with both of your feet are
broken.
And um,
and then,
but when I started getting
back into it and I'm like,
I remember I brought a girl back back to
my hotel when I still had this fucking
vacuum,
uh,
on my foot and I was just like,
it was fucking awkward and I hadn't
had sex in like a year or two.
So I'm like trying to figure
out how to have sex again.
I got a fucking vacuum
attached to my foot hole.
Who is your health like,
I mean,
what kind of like energy
levels did you have?
It would seem like if
you're going through,
your body's trying to repair itself for
such a long period of time it has to
wear on you,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
it was,
it was more just the depression of it all.
And the stress was,
was harder than I was getting
plenty of sleep and stuff.
But it was,
it was a depressing time,
but ultimately it was kind of,
it was kind of good in a way,
um,
in building and some,
a little bit,
I mean,
I got a good of,
um,
I,
so,
I mean,
when I started in,
in Boston and I started doing comedy,
I was like fearless.
I would do like the ballsiest stuff,
always trying new material and
I just did not give a shit.
And I got a lot of attention for it.
And I caught some breaks early on.
And once I started making
money and doing the road,
it was like,
then you're worried about like getting
negative comment cards and all this shit.
And that's like my livelihood.
And it was,
it was just watering down what I was
doing and I wasn't fearless on stage
anymore.
Um,
Eh,
and,
and so after breaking my feet and having
three months of my parents' house,
it kind of was just like,
I don't give a fuck anymore.
I'm just doing exactly what I want to do.
And it was,
it was,
uh,
it really created a change in my career.
I thought that album and like the new
act that I'm doing now or the best that
I've ever been.
How long ago was the incident and the
accident and how long did it take you to
recover?
Um,
so it was,
it was two years ago,
um,
in May.
And then I,
about one year in I started using
a cane and then that's when I,
that was really hard when I started
using a cane because I was like,
yes,
the light at the end of the tunnel.
And then I realized,
oh,
every other stuff that I
take for the rest of my life,
I think it's going to hurt
just every other step.
And so it's like always on.
That's why,
that's why I take kratom before podcasts
because there's always like a part of
my brain that can't stop talking.
That's can't stop thinking
about my stupid fucking foot.
Is it,
is it hurting you right now?
Um,
no.
Right now it feels fine,
but when you walk here,
um,
well the cardamom helps,
but if I,
if I'm not on that,
most days it's just like
having a pretty sore foot.
And then some days,
like probably now it's,
it's coming along better than
I thought it would actually,
well,
three days out of a month I have like
this streak and I don't know what causes
it.
I don't know if it's inactivity,
the weather,
whatever.
I have a streak of like
three days where I can just,
Eh,
where I should be using a cane again,
where if you saw me,
you'd be like,
what's wrong with that guy?
Years later.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
Oh,
about a year and a half
after I started using a cane,
so both eyes on a cane for
about six months and then
I started going without the
cane and just using it sometimes.
And uh,
yeah,
so it's been quite an ordeal.
Okay.
Yeah.